you said something in an interview then
I don't even know if you knew that but I
knew they were asking you about where
you're gonna do black characters you're
going to be blackity black black and
they're black black and that's what
you're gonna do and you actually said no
I want to do characters
[Applause]
I know this young man says he had to
take top choral cornrows so much Wow oh
my just thinking a whole decade yeah
yeah I'm probably like my late teens
like me so I was like wow yeah I'll tell
you one specific thing what we're not
even on a few members is just we came to
LA there's this thing called the
basketball what was the but it was
really League for people who weren't
athletic who were in movies who wanted
to look good you know on the court you
know cuz her girlfriends was coming at
wiser and then he shows up you
understand why his name is Michael
Jordan and he didn't move on some actor
in the act he didn't move the actor
Lawson an actor ended up in the parking
lot and he was just killing everybody
know was just amazing to watch I think
they complained about you it was like we
don't he's too it like this doesn't go
with my narrative yeah I'm thinking that
Ely was probably one of the first times
we started to meet but just so but but
you know what what I'll say about about
you is that nothing really change is
like you know you you feel you feel down
now I was one of things like it's coming
from Jersey you know moving to LA like
most China you followed a dream you know
grind hopefully become successful you
know as an actor and stuff like that and
you know you will find these little
groups and cliques you know people that
would hang out and somehow I just kind
of you know finessed my way until I you
know on the course I I know I could hoop
so it's like we at least we can figure
this out it was you know in the girls
which really made them want to kick you
out to leave yeah but now but but but
Jamie was one of the you know the first
people that I met in Los Angeles that
really kind of took me out of yeah took
him on his wing and gave it bison and
you know he saw what I was trying to do
and he wanted to you know protect me
from some of the pitfalls and obstacles
there you know they're out in LA and
yeah because live in LA is living in LA
is interesting because it it is a place
of plastic what I feel but there's also
a place where artists go and I felt like
seeing you there was more to you than
just I think just surface now I don't
know what I or any of my homies were
reading but there wasn't a special
quality about you that was like it's
interesting and even everything that we
watched you do there was a certain type
of it's weird to say this the it thing
or the integrity or or if it was a
younger verb when that was this one
around that the swag the the the our say
this the ingredients of what it what it
is in being a a movie star along with
the type of materials you've got to get
into as an actor because I do think that
there are two sides I think there's
celebrity in the news too
- but you you gave me the energy that
you wanted both that you wanted the
whatever you were doing to be just
wanted to compete i'ma tell you you want
to compete and it was a thing it was
interesting to take the competition but
also you said something in an interview
then I don't even know if you knew that
but I knew they were asking you about
where you're gonna do black characters
you're gonna be blackity black black and
they're black black and that's what
you're gonna do and you actually said
nope I want to do characters I don't
want to be what was it was the way I
thought about it was just like you know
it's always a bias somewhere it seemed
branching right so even writers know
there's not a lot of you know successful
black writers at RIT
you know like for the you know big
movies and at the time you know it
wasn't really that there wasn't enough
material being written for us that
wasn't very stereotypical right I've
been blessed with my career to play some
stereotypical characters that the lasted
the test of time that I that that just
was bigger than that box that they tried
to bring in you know any wire fried not
life stuff like that the characters they
talk about the what talk about the wire
because I believe in the interview you
did reference to that but talk about the
significance of the way I mean the wire
for me was at a time where you know
Wallace you know corner boy you know but
he was the heartbeat of season 1 he was
the heartbeat of that show everybody
loved him so when he died it hurt
everyone in the door but you know you
never want to get that you know the
trailer could you know is you know you
know saying way to get scripts you know
I said yeah you want to show with nobody
save you always just want to skin it
makes me so I died today exactly so so
while this is one of those characters
that everybody watched everybody in
Hollywood watched all the right people
the cast and directors and producers you
know saying the studio execs you know
they so when the right people that are
going to eventually see your name come
I state this you know if when it comes
to different jobs and rules you know it
helps that they're a fan of certain
things right in the wild is one of those
characters that really did that for me
but my mentality behind it all was like
you know I want to play the roles that
no Brad Pitt's with my favorite is you
know Leonardo DiCaprio's when my
favorite Tom Hanks Giovanni Ribisi I'm
saying Edward Norton you know these are
cats that that that I really enjoy you
would then self gonna obviously think
I'm saying Mount Rushmore of actors but
I would hate sin about being an audition
you know for the the role of the year
yes I'm saying that's that's not the one
of the stereotypical you know characters
and you would see everybody from you
know from ages 40 down the 17 going out
for this one role right and then
everybody sitting in you know an
audition room looking at each other like
I'm not afraid to speak you notice about
this whole pity attention and my way
around that was just like look man I
want to play roles that are people of
course me with the skin that I have the
person that I am stepping into that
character I'm gonna make it inherently
black that's what I'm gonna be so I told
my agents and everybody look I want to
go out for every role that's written for
you know like the corporation man know I
mean I want I want those roles because
when I take that role I'm gonna make it
me you know alright but it's just people
it just carries and why why don't you
feel I guess I'm saying I understand it
but what gave you that that would give
you that edge what made you think that
we did you just see all this clutter you
just said I don't want to be in that box
uh it was just one of those things were
like how do you reverse engineering the
problem right you know I'm saying like
it was you know I started thinking back
like why I never saw a lot of your
generation at each other's premieres
right when I'm saying like oh I'll never
seen this person that that person is for
me or that person at that person like
then why is that you know I mean like
what what's the the subtext then like
why aren't they supporting or why is it
and if they are why isn't it why can't I
see
I'm saying so and then I started
thinking about my own circumstances with
other actors that are in my generation
and you know you see them out and people
won't speak they won't say this up
because it may kind of time she was a
competition and I and I couldn't I
couldn't be friendly with my competition
oh he got that role that I won in that
so it was a Southern suppose like man
there's more material out there right
for all of us right you know that's the
outside of that one project that one
role a year which has really started to
spark the production company the desire
to create I need to create material
create content you know then that
wouldn't be an issue
and I enjoy you know seeing somebody
strengths you know and trying to China
light help them succeed and Michael it's
tough to look at you coming in all
good-looking that starts you know that
starts a lot of cantankerous Ennis if we
even talked about that I haven't told
you about yeah I said I said you're so
nice which is rare cuz you to be this
high in your career do you know a little
bit of most people get a little full
sprinkled or net a little bit yeah some
people have a little bat a little pop in
a little pocket of some I sprinkle it on
this there once they said you know they
started talking through people you don't
do that which makes it it makes people
that you could maybe maybe it makes it
even tougher that you are nice but I I
tell you what the fact that you have
that weight of thinking of that you want
to to relieve that tension is amazing in
I just like it's wrong man I just like
is wrong you know like but you
understand that yeah you understand this
one
that that when then I would say this
with you I would tell this to you I said
hey keep moving
yeah don't don't don't don't worry about
all of those things and all of those
people and all those things that are
trying to get you distracted but yeah
you got something special and I and I I
say even come on with with just me mercy
but going back to like your narrative
and Fruitvale station is that something
that you cuz now we're looking now we're
looking back but is that something that
when you took that type of movie was
that on purpose was meaning like a
narrative for us for our culture yeah
yeah that was that was my first real
intention to move where I had a choice
cuz you know people think is you're an
actor oh you you know these roles and
you know Church that you're doing that
oh I had like you know 10 choices and I
decided you that was an odd that's the
what I booked but I think that was the
first one that I really and I'm cooler
and that was that was beyond above me
you know I'm saying that that's that's
the universe putting people together the
way the way it just worked out because
Ryan just so happened to be coming you
know first out at USC film school you
know his uh you know you know it's kind
of a senior project you know I'm saying
this script that he that he wrote with
me in mind that I didn't know at the
time I was coming back from South Africa
I was got from the students movie called
Chronicle and I was like man I want to
do a I was at a crossroad I said I
wanted to do I want to do an independent
film I want to do something that can
show I can act I want to I want to know
I'm gonna answer this question myself I
want to be able to be a leading man you
know I'm saying I want to know if I if
that's where I fall cuz I know you could
be extremely talented and not open for
open big movements I'm saying but but I
wanted to know
where where I stood where I felt and
also check my Martin shooting
mmm had happened a month prior before
that and I just remember being
frustrated you know going online at the
time it might have been on black planet
I don't know what something I was
amazing something like there was
something wrong I was like I kept
remember just writing post you know of
how I felt as a black man or whatever at
the time and deleting it you know I'm
saying like a my own you know what's
sake I can't say that I was too angry I
said I don't know
how am i how do i express myself I'm not
about frustrated so when when fruit
fills you know it was called a fruit of
the time when fruit came along I was
ready and I was in tears and I was like
man this is this is it this is this is
my way to to tell people how I'm feeling
you know to express myself you don't
want to own it on on hopefully you know
we never knew what the movie was gonna
be is like you know shot up for $90,000
and some duct tape you know it was it
was a you know we barely got it made and
and I could see if I can carry yourself
you know so you checked off all the
boxes so you know I met Ryan you know 20
minutes in the conversation just talking
to his brother I was like oh man this is
my guy like if we were to went to school
we would've grew up together here to be
one of my closest friends my best friend
so now we just saw a kinship in one
another he told me like look Mike you
know I think you you know wildly
talented let's go show the world you
know let's go do this you know I mean
let's go let's go tell this story I
think it's important let's get and we
both was like all right let's go let's
do it was great man and anything we did
and you know what I tell you all the
time when I went and saw that movie I
took some guys will be men at a very
very tough I'm saying very like you know
macho and then we watched you capture us
in that performance
I heard sniffles from these guys and I
knowing what they didn't have a cold I'm
saying they was like they were broken
down with it honey
you know what's interesting about you
and I say this I think swag matches swag
because you and Ryan have this sort of
coolness about you getting like I think
that was a
that was the the really was the Stars
lighten up yeah and you know define the
director who understood me spoke my
language and I'm saying the same age
like the same things can like our
shorthand was like incredible you know
you know we had a limited time we only
had you know the shooting shot in 21
days I don't want to say it was a quick
shoot and and we maximized every take
man and I think our relationship and
being able to like speak to one another
like quickly and get it really lent
itself to that and he you know and he
brought up no Creed I ain't even shot
one frame he was pitching free to MGM
before we even started shooting day once
we just Asian yeah and it was like the I
come on let's do it
you know I mean so it was the way things
started to line up and then right after
Creed you know no Black Panther to slow
down you just go in and let you can't
you can't go in and did it first of all
creep what that did what I believe that
did I always I always look to love Jones
as a template for me and my generation
love Jones like wow that's that's black
love that's that's universal love
anybody that wants it and Creed I was
like oh my goodness this is so amazing
love that you that love story along with
the iconic persons you play about that
just for a second no I'm it was cool it
was like one of those things where you
know obviously coming from the world of
Rocky you know that franchise no I mean
Apollo Creed you know I never
transformed my body before I wanted you
know I was not a challenge
like I wanted to see you look at you
know sly and Carl Weathers you know
saying it was and you know it was
chiseled yes I was like God I was like
man that's that's that's impressive
I wouldn't I want to know if I can do
that you know so did it so we put the
time in the gym got the body right you
didn't do like me like I have a spank on
you didn't spank it out see this is all
Spang Spang it's not it was one of those
things were just kind of like wanted to
I knew what we were following I nobody
get all the comparisons to like you know
what Rocky was and you know we wanted to
distinguish us as our own franchise and
our own story you know Ryan came up with
that entire idea and you know pitched it
and we finally got everybody on board
and we went out and I think we executed
it in a big way
you know while paying homage to you know
what slide building and the whole you
know rocky world we wanted to
distinguish you know saying what what it
would be like you know told through our
lens yeah that's what you wanted to do
so black panther came around came along
that was you know kill monger was
another narrative that we wanted to push
and that was that was a big one and you
know so our relationship is very unique
special go from improve the station a
small movie that won our hearts and then
to go to the biggest movie in the world
and black panther playing kill monger
but still having the same narratives
that we could feed off of a now just
mercy I have to say this I say it all
the time we are so appreciative of you
and keeping that narrative life they
convicted an innocent man
I was always taught to fight for the
people who need to help me most you
don't know what it is yeah they ain't
got had no evidence how many of you all
were with Walter that morning
you ain't quit miss no sir in front of
him behind the camera you were
absolutely amazing talk about the birth
of just mercy how did that come about it
was you know my agent kind of brought
this uh this book to me and was like
this is something that you know I want
you to you know read and you know figure
out if it's something you think you know
you can wrap your head around it and um
and I was a little bit embarrassed once
I started to find out more information
about who Bryan Stevenson was I was like
why don't I know this guy you know like
why isn't he more of a household name
why isn't you know his work is
incredible and what he's doing is you
know exactly what it's the remedy to my
frustrations as a young black man
dealing with all these issues of police
brutality human you know mass
incarceration of you know unfair
citizens and death row in the whole
situation so it was I got a chance to
watch his TED talk listen to him speak a
chance to meet him a few times yeah you
know and I was blown away I was
intimidated actually because you know
he's much more I thought he was much
better of a person than I was so I was
like man I got to get my life I got to
vet it I gotta try harder because you
got you know dedicated his life to a
cause and he's continued to like you
know beat that drum of justice so me so
that all happened and and uh you know
met him signed on to do it you know I
think he was filling me out see if you
know if I was worthy enough to play I'm
sure he was absolutely happy to be
Jordan with flames right see this is a
lawyer yeah who
Tsubasa's playing a lawyer who you know
who started the eji equal justice
initiative who you know who fights for
wrongly accused and unfair sentence
black and brown people or poor
disfavored you know people that have
been condemned
he works to get them exonerated and he
fights for just the the the writing of a
racially biased judicial system right
long so I had to have the honor of
playing him so anyway that got that
together me and destin cretton director
of short-term 12 you know a friend of
Ryan's we started cracking together a
script not trying to develop the stories
out of this huge memoir with so many as
so much material and trying to figure
out how do we make this in you know into
our two-hour film so we start to pull
pull stories and work on it over the
next couple of years this is about you
know three four years in the making and
and then we started to get down to you
know Studios know who's gonna distribute
this thing I wanna brother stepped up in
a really big way
you know we starting about cast the case
of Walter McMillian with the movie is
kind of based around and you know I had
you know being in a position you know I
was one of the producers you know and
somebody that you know I felt I knew
would knock it out of the park somebody
you know it's screen you know his name
was you know it was you you know my
mentor Big Brother somebody who you know
I consider on the on the Mount Rushmore
one of the goats in the game along with
brie Larson you know rob Morgan and
O'Shea Jackson and Kara Kendrick and Tim
Blake Nelson and you know many other
talented cast that that um you know they
came together to help make this thing
come come about the movie is um I'm
really proud of you know and a lot of a
lotta love in a lot of ways yeah it was
one of the first films under Warner
Brothers adopted the inclusion writer
along with my production company we
helped write the inclusion writer that
all of Warner media actually hires under
so all their companies under their
umbrella uses our include inclusion act
as well so you know everybody knew this
story was very important from you know
the studio to the director
all the way down to the PAS it was a
production that was a very diverse crew
and everybody knew how important it was
so everybody you know went the extra
mile to make sure the story the story
was right well I was absolutely honored
and humbled to get that call to to play
this character minute and I thank you
again it's like our personal
conversation is basically you've given
me an opportunity to have my artistic
integrity back in an intact to and to
hear the story of this Walter McMillian
person who was wrongly accused of in
Alabama coming from his job as a tree
poping owning chopping down trees
he's wrongly accused of killing someone
in a city that had never been in and and
just so a matter of fact they put him in
jail and then put him on death row I
thought that while I'm in with both feet
on this because it's so necessary and
even today even though this was 30 years
ago the 1986-87 when it was those those
types of things are still going on like
those cases and in Texas and and so many
other places and I just thought that I
was in with both feet and then putting
Walter McMillian putting the skin on him
having a father had been in the jail
himself for $25 worth of illegal
substance I drew one I drew upon that I
remember when we had to shoot those
scenes in the jail cell on how I felt
when you know they're putting cuffs on
me and I'm a person of perception I
don't like the perception I'm seeing
anybody in jail but I know those just
like getting the cuffs on really like
put me in the mindset of like wow this
person's life this is put up side
they're his family everybody's affected
and then all of a sudden an angel of a
person Bryan Stevenson played by you it
was just it was just mad
go on set it's such a necessary
storyline and I applaud you for bringing
it to bring that to everybody I
appreciate I think it's important you
know you know it's a movie that will
take you through a range of emotions
hopefully you you end up feeling you
know walking out of the theater when you
get finished watching it that you know
you want to feel like you want to be a
part of solution you want to i want this
to inspire conversation and to provoke
thought and to sometimes the criminal
justice system it's such a big issue
that it it almost paralyzed a person to
not wanting to do anything you know so
that what can I do to be to a nice big
thing so I'm just gonna do nothing and I
think that's the the wrong perspective
to hide it you can do something you you
know voting is extremely important to
you know educate yourself - you know
what prosecutors you know or in your
local community who are they you know
who who is you know you know what
policies are being put in place you know
you know all the information is at your
fingertips you just got to do a little
bit of you know inquiring about certain
things just so you can be knowledgeable
so you can learn you know how you vote
in directly effective sources in your
environment so um yeah there's a million
things good you know going going to EJ
York you know Bryan Stevenson is setting
up this you know a lot of actionable
things on his website that you can do if
you feel some you know move to do so but
you know I heard you say that many times
the things that we go online about the
things that we talk about all these
issues all these injustice that are
happening that we're going on social
media and we and then we have these
rants and we have this you know these
revolutions and and we motional eerie
acting yes and then we get distracted in
30 minutes later we on to the next thing
on the next whatever it is you know all
the things that we're talking about you
know Bryan Stevenson is actively
fighting every
you know so you know I think this is all
hands on deck as you say this is a you
know everybody needs to get involved and
and and doing whatever they can to see
this movie you know outside of the
movies what it represents yeah but but
it makes it absolutely people need to
see it because it's special and I want
to jump into this one particular
situation you when you embody Brad
Stevenson absolutely incredibly but the
the scene in the courtroom I talk about
this all the time that specifically
because I think this is so important the
scene of you in the courtroom this
wonderful speech that I watched you
craft and it was so important why was
you've said in interviews that that
speech you looked in the script and you
looked you went straight to that speech
like this is the most important yeah
thing and I absolutely talk of that I
think that because the you know as an
actor you look through a script and
there's certain things that you just
circle that's like okay I can't wait to
get that one it was a pivotal moment in
the movie it was a pivotal moment and
watching McMillan's case you know
everything was kind of resting on this
on this home on this argument you know
and and I wanted to get it right so bad
I think it's important because it really
goes into the human condition it really
goes into how reviewed it goes into the
perception that people have on you know
people of color people that are you know
have looked like us and and and then we
can't be a fair system we can't be a
system that calls ourselves just if we
treat people that are rich and guilty
different than if you're poor and
innocent so Bryan Stevenson you know is
very good at being reserved
I'd be methodical would being strategic
you know but in this one in this one
scene he got it you saw him kind of take
all of his strategy and kind of just
balling into one and
and ultimately uh you know helped help
get watermelons case overturned so and
that to me that speech was amazing
and I'm just gonna tell you as a fan
watching you walk that speech down you
you finished that speech and what you
didn't see behind you was the extras in
this courtroom gave you a standing
ovation I went to congratulate you you
you know it was like you as like as we
say in church you had to hold the girl
she had the spirit and you walked out I
text you and told me that was amazing
performance and the people in the fourth
row are weeping and then then all of a
sudden the movie is being seen by people
for the first time in the biggest way
it's a Toronto Film Festival which is I
mean for those of you watching that's
like our Superbowl in a sense and I
whispered to you I said hey man you're
gonna be surprised when people see this
I highly react and we walked out on that
stage after the movie had just been seen
and Toronto and when you walked up they
give you a standing ovation how'd that
make you feel yeah humble man honored
honestly you know someone's we put so
much into this movie and put so much
into making it we know how important it
was but you know you never really know
exactly how people are gonna react to it
so when you see people appreciate the
work and one of the biggest things I
took away from that was the the Q&A we
had asked after the questions people
were asking was what could I do how do I
make a difference how do I where do I
sign up what's going on I feel some type
of way and that confirmed that we had
something that was going to make people
thinking and many people start having
conversation so if you know the voice of
the people is very powerful you know the
people are spoken as a phrase goes back
to you know beginning a time so you you
you know we collectively get together
about something
then we want to see a change we can
demand it so hopefully they feel
passionate about the subject enough that
they want to demand some type of change
that's great well I'm gonna call you
Santa Claus brother because you're
giving us a gift everybody go out and
see just mercy I'm happy to be a part of
it in January
open a wide open up
[Music]